i'm very happy and grateful to have been
invited to present here at stoicon x
brazil
2020 so the topic that
i'm going to be talking about is the
doctrine
of the indifference and why it is that
stoics shouldn't be completely
indifferent
to the indifference before i get started
i'd like to
say thanks of course to everybody who's
watching
to claudia for the invitation and for
organizing this great event
and especially to the translators who
are going to make it possible for us to
communicate across
different languages as somebody who
engages in translation work myself
i know how difficult that work can be
and i
am incredibly grateful for it my
portuguese
extends to basically being able to say
muito obragado
and that's about it so let me jump right
into
my presentation then the key issue here
is that one of the distinctive features
of the stoic school is what we call the
doctrine
of the indifference namely that the idea
that there
are things that are good things that are
bad and then a wide range of other
things
that are actually indifferent in greek
diaphora meaning the things that don't
make a difference and we can say don't
make a difference in what way well
we'll get to that in a moment and
stoicism is
not unique in saying that some things
just don't have any value
or don't make a difference at all
aristotelians can say that epicureans
can say that pretty much
anybody can say that what makes stoicism
unique
is that there's so many things that go
into that
so you know if we think about wealth
as a prime example that we're going to
talk about a little bit later on
being wealthy being poor being in the
middle
all of that is strictly speaking
indifferent from a
stoic perspective and so stoics talk
about
things outside of our control or things
that are externals
being indifferent instead of talking the
way that other virtue ethicists do
uh talking about things being lesser
goods
or lesser bads or evils so for example
an aristotelian would say
that pleasure is not the good but it is
a
good it's not something that is
indifferent and pain is not
the bad but it certainly is a bad thing
stoics would say no those things are
actually
indifference and it's very easy to
gather the
impression that we we shouldn't care
about
externals or indifference at all and
that would come from
a you might say selective or superficial
reading of stoic text but there are some
doctrines that for example epictetus is
going to give us
that would lead us to that conclusion
quite easily when he tells us
that we should withdraw our desire and
aversion from
externals as much as possible is that
not telling us we should be indifferent
to them
when we should say to things you are
nothing to me that's being indifferent
as well
when we say that nothing external can
really harm or
benefit us that sounds like we're being
indifferent
and then when we say that the only
things that really matter
are vice and virtue misery and
happiness that seems like we're saying
everything else should just be
you know left to to do what it's going
to do we shouldn't care about it
we shouldn't be concerned about it and
this can go so far
as to say we shouldn't even worry about
what other people
think or feel and i think if we go too
far
with that that's a bit of a dangerous
view some people like that because
uh this this doctrine can be quite
comforting or consoling the view that we
can sort of wall
ourselves up in ourselves and be these
individuals
who don't have to be connected with the
the rest of the
myriad things of the world we don't have
to be
emotionally invested we don't have to
have worries or anxieties or have
responses
or responsibilities but we do have
responsibilities
and that's where we should start
thinking about this before that though
let's let's look at something that
marcus aurelius says
as you know sort of representative of
this he says
to live a good life we have the
potential for it if we can learn to
be indifferent to what makes no
difference
this is how we learn looking at each
thing both the parts and the whole
keeping in mind that none of them can
dictate how we perceive it
they don't impose themselves on us and
he goes on
telling us traditional stoic ideas but
the core idea there is that
the things that don't make a difference
we should be indifferent to them
later on he tells us that we can use
nature as the index for this
some things nature is indifferent too
if it privileged one over the other it
would hardly have created both
and if we want to follow nature to be of
one mind with it
we need to share in notice what he says
its
indifference to privilege pleasure over
pain life over death fame over anonymity
is clearly blasphemous nature doesn't do
that
and when i say that nature is
indifferent to them i mean that they
happen indifferently at different times
to the things that exist and the things
that come into being after them
through some ancient degree of
providence so once again we see
well nature is indifferent to these
things we should imitate nature in this
respect we should
follow nature doesn't this sound like
traditional stoic
ideas and values well it sounds like
some of them
but we have to contextualize these so
let's look at the indifference very
briefly like i mentioned ah diaphoria
the things that don't make a difference
and so
don't make a difference in in what way
here's where we want to turn to diogenes
liertes who
summarizes stoic doctrine in book seven
of his lives of the philosophers and he
tells us that
there are two different meanings to
indifferent according to the stoics
one is things that do not contribute to
happiness or
misery you can be happy or miserable
without them but
use of them in certain ways contributes
to happiness or misery we're going to
come back to that notion of use
in just a few minutes the other things
that he says that
are indifferent are things that have no
power to stir
inclination towards or against and the
word that he's using there
is uh the same word that we can
translate as choice
and rejection jorme and afforme you see
these
already when epictetus tells us that
these are things that we actually have
control over in
and caridian one and in discourses uh
1-1
so what are examples of things that are
indifferent wealth
versus poverty from a stoic perspective
neither being wealthy nor being poor is
going to make us happy or miserable
because neither of them are going to
make us virtuous or vicious
they can play a role in that though pain
versus pleasure obviously we are averse
to pain
but from a stoic perspective the
aversion that we have towards pain
should not be the same sort of reaction
as we do
when we have horror or we turn away from
vice health versus illness
this is something that many of us
experience firsthand
isn't it high status versus low status
physical attractiveness versus physical
ugliness why are these things
indifference
they're not indifferent because they
don't matter at all
they are they do have some value they
don't have value to the extent of making
us happy or miserable
in the genuine sense and having them
doesn't make us good or bad
so a painful life is not necessarily a
bad life you can live with chronic pain
and be a virtuous person you can also
let your chronic pain get to you and be
a miserable
person and and you know let everybody
down and do all sorts of other things
just like you
if you're poor it may be harder in some
respects to
you know exercise virtue not just
because you need
you know money as a means or something
like that but because you're presented
with so many
things that make it difficult right but
they don't buy themselves determine
anything so you know a common mistake
is to think that these don't matter at
all from a stoic perspective there's a
tendency
to equate the indifferent the externals
what's not in in my control to the to
the degree that we withdraw from all of
these and that goes against
a stoic approach as a matter of fact
there might even be a sort of
pridefulness in
this withdrawal from everything in that
way we should think about
whether the the indifference do have any
value if they don't have the value that
makes us happy or miserable
what what do they have so there's a very
important distinction that's made
between the classical stoics and some
other philosophers
on this matter if you want to see the
best discussion of this go to cicero's
on the ends and see what he has to say
about pyro
and aristo they said that nothing
other than virtue mattered as far as
human happiness
and as far as our duties the cynics also
seem to be saying something like that
getting this wrong actually means
abandoning stoicism
some things do have value and others
don't there are some
genuinely indifferent matters some of
the examples that the stoics used where
whether your finger is straight or bent
picking up something along the way of
walking
like a twig interestingly one of the
things that they actually
said wasn't indifferent pale or dark
skin
we should think about that and one
that they use is a very great example is
the number of
hairs on your head even or odd you know
i've got a nice
thick head of hair here unless we're
like you know betting on it or something
like that
who cares it doesn't matter it doesn't
make any difference to anything
there's nothing that rides on the number
of hairs on my head
but there are on other matters right
so the the classic stoics introduce this
distinction between
on the one hand preferred indifference
and on the other hand
rejected indifference and this means
things that
other people would consider to be good
or bad but usually
lesser goods or lesser bads by
comparison to justice
or to virtue rather right virtue justice
as one of the virtues
the stoics say no these are indifference
but they have a kind of value we can
prefer them
we can reject them we can prefer wealth
we can reject
poverty but none of them are going to
make us necessarily
virtuous and so they do have positive or
negative value
in in diagonalities we get this
formulation of they can contribute to
harmonious living
some preferred indifference are so
because they're for the sake of
something else they are
useful wealth is a useful tool
for doing things right poverty is being
impeded in that respect seneca
talks about death in letter 82 he says
death is an indifferent among the things
that are not
bad and yet have a semblance of badness
not something one can easily
ignore and the indifference do have
relations to each other diogenes of
babylon we discover
in i believe it's on duties tells us
that
wealth does have something to contribute
to health this is cicero telling us what
diogenes the fourth skull arc had to say
and so how can we
make something out of indifference how
can we not be indifferent
to them there's a lot of ways and i'm
only going to go into two
main discussions of it here because i
want to leave plenty of time for us to
discuss matters so i mentioned that
there's this this idea
of use the use or crisis
in greek uss in latin of indifference
it can also be translated as dealing
with
our approach towards things and
epictetus leads
the way in this respect he tells us that
while some things are indifferent and
this is in a chapter on
indifference in things in book two of
the discourses
some things are indifferent but our use
of them
is not indifferent how we use them how
we deal with them
what we do with them that is something
that
is up to us epheme in greek
something that we are responsible for
something that is good or bad
on our part and he talks uh for example
about the hypothetical syllogism the
hypothetical syllogism that's a matter
of indifference you know
it's just a bit of logic over here an
argument that's being made
but the judgment we make about it is not
indifferent he says
we are either involved in knowledge or
opinion or delusion and that matters
because that has to do with wisdom
or with foolishness so he tells us that
we
really need to be careful that is we
have to have concern
rather than being careless the word for
that is
amelis when it comes to indifferent
things because the use of them is not
indifferent he tells us that the
materials the hulei
the in in greek are not are indifferent
but the use that we make of them is not
so we need to imitate those who play a a
game like those who are playing dice
or playing ball whether or not things go
a certain way that's indifferent but
what
whether we do our job whether we do a
good job that is up to us
so using indifference carelessly is bad
for the pro-irasis
it's contrary to nature for it the other
thing i'll mention very briefly
is that the virtues far from being a
withdrawal from the indifference
they have to do with how we use
and arrange and prioritize the
indifference
you know because virtue is good and not
an indifferent it's a mistake
to think as some people do that it would
not be concerned with things that are
indifferent
the stoics are rejecting this idea this
doctrine
that that cicero discusses he tells us
if we maintain that all things were
completely indifferent the whole of life
would be thrown into confusion
and no function or task could be found
for wisdom
the most important of the virtues right
since there would be no distinction
between the things that pertain to the
conduct of life
and no choice need be exercised among
them
seneca in letter 92 gives us some great
examples about
pursuing and using preferred
indifference he tells us that
taking them is an exercise of good
judgment and think about these examples
he's using
putting on clean clothing taking a walk
in the proper way
dining as one should there's an
intention there of maintaining a measure
that pertains to
reason in letter 82 he also tells us
nothing is glorious that does not
involve
indifference illness pain poverty death
none of them are glorious in themselves
as a matter of fact we'd like to not
have those if we could
but nothing is glorious without them
virtue meets and handles them
each object takes on a splendor not its
own when virtue
is added to it so i want to close here
by saying
we really there are some things that we
could be indifferent to you know the
number of hairs on my head we don't have
to care about that right
there are a lot of things that we
probably should be indifferent to
the results of how things turn out with
our intentions
but there are many things concerning the
indifference
that we should not be indifferent to at
all as a matter of fact we should be
very
concerned and careful about them in a
rational way
if we want to follow the teachings of
the stoics
so thank you very much i'm delighted as
i said to be here
and i look forward to seeing what
questions you have about this matter and
hopefully having a good dialogue going
you